Varys: The Maesters tell us that Aegon came
to Westeros with fire and blood, and hammered
six kingdoms into one.
The fire he undoubtedly brought, as the Kings
of the Rock, Reach, and Iron Islands learned.
Aegon's own son, Maegor the Cruel, was killed
by the very Iron Throne his father had forged
if you believe the tales.
If you don't, then perhaps "the Cruel" is
not a wise name for a king to earn.
Daeron, First of His Name, tried to finish
his ancestors' work and bring Dorne into the
fold.
For his efforts, he lost sixty thousand men
and his own life of eighteen years.
During the great Targaryen civil war known
as "the Dance of the Dragons," a king and
queen each vied for the throne, dividing their
house and its dragons against each other.
By the war's end, King's Landing was smashed,
cities razed and sacked never to be rebuilt,
and dragons had faded from this world.
Jaime Lannister:For centuries, the Kingsguard
have been the glory of the realm.
Aegon the Conqueror had established the order
as his personal guardians after uniting Westeros
with fire and blood.
He knew that some of his subjects wouldn't
take to conquest, and his dragons were no
use against knives in the dark.
No doubt surrounding himself with the greatest
knights in Westeros made his rule more palatable
and less foreign as well.
Everyone in his kingdoms soon knew the names
and some of the songs of the Kingsguard.
I certainly did from earliest days.
Bronn: There was one Kingsguard (I forgot
the bastard's name) who swore an oath to his
dying Targaryen king to crown his daughter
after him.
The very night that king died, this Kingsguard
crowned the king's son instead.
When an old man on the small council dared
to protest, this honorable knight opened his
throat.
The bastard died in the very civil war he
started along with the old king's son, daughter,
and most of their dragons.
And the Kingsguard?
All that duty and honor and not enough brains
to figure out which Targaryen to give it to.
Twin brothers even ended up on opposite sides,
died with tears on their cheeks as they cut
each other down.
I suppose I should think that's tragic, but
stupid men do stupid things every day and
nobody cries over them.
Petyr Baelish: As little more than a boy,
Ser Criston Cole replaced the legendary Ser
RyamRedwyne on the Kingsguard and soon rose
to Lord Commander.
But knights only know one way to settle disputes.
When Prince Aegon's father died, SerCriston
slit the throat of an advisor who objected
to Aegon's ascension over his aunt, the anointed
heir.
His actions so pleased the new King, Aegon,
Second of His Name, that he appointed SerCriston
as his Hand in the ensuing civil war called
the Dance of Dragons.
Neither SerCriston nor the King nor even the
Targaryen dragons would survive it.
Viserys Targaryen: The Targaryen dynasty united
the Seven Kingdoms and lasted nearly three
centuries.
It was a dynasty forged in fire, sealed in
blood, and destroyed by rebellion.
The Targaryens are blood of the dragon, descended
from the nobility of ancient Valyria, a once-mighty
empire in the east.
When the cataclysmic Doom laid waste of Valyria
and its people, the Targaryens survived, having
settled in the island fortress of Dragonstone
years before.
They remained there for a century until the
rise of Aegon the Conqueror.
Instead of attempting to reclaim the eastern
lands of his ancestors, Aegon sailed west
for the Seven Kingdoms, his sisters Visenya
and Rhaenys at his side.
To keep the bloodlines pure, Aegon continued
the custom of his Valyrian ancestors and took
both of his sisters to wives.
Together, they came ashore on the eastern
coast of Westeros.
Their blazon: a dragon with three heads, representing
Aegon and his sister-wives.
Their words: "Fire and Blood."
While their host was small when compared to
the armies of the Seven Kingdoms, Aegon and
his sisters had a secret weapon.
The last of the dragons.
He conquered every kingdom, save Dorne, which
eventually bowed to Targaryen rule a century
later.
He had the swords of his enemies melted down
by the fiery breath of his dragon, Balerion
the Black Dread, and forged into the Iron
Throne.
The capital city of King's Landing was built
on the eastern coast, where Aegon and his
sisters first came ashore.
And Aegon ordered the construction of a royal
castle on its highest hill, the Red Keep.
Samwell Tarly: According to legend, House
Targaryen survived the Doom of Valyria thanks
to Daenys the Dreamer, who foresaw the calamity
and convinced her father to flee their homeland.
It could be true.
The Targaryens were always a bit more.
Viserys Targaryen:Twelve years before the
Doom, despite the sneers of his rivals, Aenar
Targaryen abandoned the capital with his family.
Legends claim that his daughter foresaw the
destruction of the city in a dream.
More likely, Aenar met with some mishap at
court and chose exile over execution.
He and House Targaryen slinked away to a dreary,
remote, godforsaken island.
Forsaken no longer.
With arts now lost to the world, we transformed
a tiny outpost into Dragonstone, a fortress
fit for the last Dragonlords.
Then Aenar's descendants settled into it like
a tomb for their lost homeland.
Until Aegon.
When he looked east, he saw the past: old,
tired, dead.
But when he looked west, he saw the future:
gold in the ground, gold in the fields, and
no dragons in the sky but his.
He and his sisters, Rhaenys and Visenya, flew
over the great continent, ostensibly visitors
to a strange land.
But when Aegon returned, he ordered construction
of a massive table carved in the shape of
Westeros, with all the notable rivers and
mountains that they had seen.
A personal map of the Seven Kingdoms, then
ruled by seven squabbling families.
House Durrandon held the Stormlands from their
seat at Storm's End, due south of Dragonstone.
House Hoare of the Iron Islands had also conquered
and enslaved the Riverlands, and ruled them
from Harrenhal, a monstrous castle rising
on the shore of the Gods Eye.
House Stark held the frozen wasteland of the
North, the oldest, largest, and emptiest of
the kingdoms.
House Lannister held the Westerlands, the
wealthiest kingdom thanks to their gold mines.
House Gardener held the Reach, the second
wealthiest kingdom thanks to their crops.
House Arryn held the Vale, or rather the Vale
held them.
The mountains were impassable except through
the Bloody Gate, which had never been taken.
House Martell held the deserts of Dorne, probably
because no one else wanted them.
Together, the Seven Kingdoms made Westeros,
a realm that wasn't yet a realm, ruled by
great families who didn't know what greatness
was.
Aegon would teach them.
With Dorne in the fold, and the Faith put
in its place, none in Westeros were left to
oppose my family, so we started opposing each
other.
In a Dance of Dragons, a Targaryen princess
tried to steal her brother's throne.
Thanks to her stupidity, most of our dragons
died.
Varys: In its time, the Dragonpit was a marvel
of the world.
Full-grown Targaryen dragons nested beneath
its massive dome, and even on the darkest
nights, the walls seemed to glow with the
fire of the great beasts inside.
Qyburn: As had the site's previous occupant,
the Sept of Remembrance, when Maegor the Cruel
blasted it with dragonfire during morning
prayers.
The screams of the dying men echoed through
King's Landing all day, and a pall of ash
and smoke hung over the city for a week.
Varys: But as it dissipated, so too did the
rebellion of the Faith Militant.
The Sept of Remembrance faded from memory,
and Maegor decided to replace a monument to
the gods with a monument to his family: the
Dragonpit.
For more than a century, the Targaryens housed
their dragons in the Dragonpit.
But dragons are not horses to be stabled or
hounds to be kenneled.
With each generation, the dragons became less.
Less massive, less swift, less long-lived.
Qyburn: And less invulnerable.
During the Dance of Dragons, two Targaryen
factions killed a handful of their family's
dragons while fighting each other.
A frenzied mob even broke into the Dragonpit
and slaughtered the five dragons chained there,
though the last managed to bring down the
roof of the great dome on its assailants.
The dragons never recovered their former strength
or numbers.
Perhaps their line had been too broken, or
perhaps others intervened to break it further.
But the last dragon grew no larger than a
cat, and its death earned Aegon, Third of
His Name, the epithet "Dragonbane."